[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vue comme chaque fois nous allons
échanger des points de vue de
préférences contradictoires sur
l'actualité du jour et je vous propose
de découvrir tout de suite
le sommaire de cette émission nous
commencerons par le brr excite on nous
avait dit que c'était impossible et
pourtant ils l'ont fait en tout cas la
première ministre theresa may est
parvenu à un accord avec la commission
européenne un marché de dupes
eh bien on essaiera de répondre à cette
interrogation nous nous intéresserons
aussi au parti socialiste faut-il qu'ils
disparaissent on en est là puisque
l'action du tout savoir s'il peut ou non
mais si ce serait souhaitable pour cette
gauche de se réformer ou de repartir de
zéro nous parlerons aussi de laurent
wauquiez
c'est ce week end aura lieu l'élection
pour la présidence des républicains le
favori at il un piste ouverte devant lui
va-t-il réussir
on essaiera aussi de répondre à cette
question et puis bien sûr nous parlerons
des deux gloires nationales disparu
cette semaine johnny hallyday et jean
d'ormesson à qui le président de la
république a rendu un hommage solennel
ce matin aux invalides
est ce qu'il symbolise l'union nationale
et que nous allons le demander à nos
quatre invités que je vais vous
présenter tout de suite bonsoir laurence
de charette
vous êtes la directrice de la rédaction
du figaro.fr bonsoir benjamin grange
pourquoi vous êtes président de dentsu
consulting et directeur général de
dentsu agissent france votre métier
c'est la communication numérique les
stratégies d' influence tout ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux et qu'on
ne voit pas forcément
bonsoir guillaume bernard bonsoir vous
êtes maître de conférence à 10 aces et
directeur de collection aux presses
universitaires de france on est très
heureux de vous accueillir dans l'équipe
votre dernier livre la guerre à droite
aura bien lieu le mouvement dextrogyre
dextrogyre savait faire mouvement vers
la droite
c'est bien ça c'est le gonflement des
idées par la droite du spectre politique
donc le glissement des idéologies de la
droite vers la gauche et s'ils voulaient
en savoir plus c'était chez des clubs
brewer c'est toujours cette équipe bauer
c'était publié l'année dernière et hervé
nathan directeur adjoint de la rédaction
de marianne est aussi avec nous
consommons soir et votre couverture de
cette semaine et ça tombe bien parce
qu'on est raccord avec notre sujet les
immortels pourquoi ils sont la france
avec naturellement
jean d'ormesson et johnny hallyday dont
on reparlera dans quelques minutes mais
pas avant de nous être intéressés aux
breaks site
et bien finalement ce n'était peut-être
pas si difficile que ça de sortir de
l'union européenne
en tout cas c'est ce que semble croire
les et admettre pardon l'accord trouvé
cette nuit entre la commission
européenne et le royaume uni le
président de la commission justement
très tôt ce matin à bruxelles se
réjouissait de cette situation ecoutez
jean claude juncker nathan vous avez dit
on ne peut pas sortir de l'union
européenne
il ya un article qu'il prévoit l'article
50 mais finalement on ne mettra jamais
en oeuvre et puis finalement c'est pas
si compliqué vous êtes un consensus
croissant chez moi j'ai toujours pensé
que c'était possible donc je fais pour
une fois c'est vrai je trouve que c'est
d'autant plus possible que finalement
les européens malgré leurs promesses
sont très en deçà des engagements qu'ils
avaient pris si on prend les trois
éléments que le lac la fin les européens
les 27
hier ceux qui vont rester dans l'union
européenne avait mis comme condition au
fait de commencer à discuter vraiment de
l'esc relations futures avec la grande
bretagne les trois conditions la dette
parce que ce qui est ce qui reste à
payer le reste à payer pour la bande
bretagne dans maintenant c'était au
moins soit ça c'était au moins 50
milliards sans doute 60 et il y avait
des estimations jusqu'à sion on a 10 à
40 milliards ça pourrait ça pourrait
suffire
donc ça signifie que éventuellement et
la sai on est totalement dans
l'ambiguïté que le gouvernement nous
assure que nous contribuables
est ce que c'est moi de parler à la
première personne du pluriel que nous
contribuables ne seront pas de notre
poche pour les contribuables
britanniques parce que c'est comme ça le
problème c'est sir est quelque chose que
les anglais ne paye pas c'est les autres
qui vont payer et français les allemands
etc
la deuxième condition c'était un statut
vraiment bétonner pour les nationaux
européens qui restera en grande bretagne
pour le moment on a dit qu'il aura accès
au marché ultra qui aura pas de
discrimination mais on voudrait sera
plus quid par exemple du rapprochement
familial
les polonais les français et c'est
qu'ils sont allés immigrés il ya 5 10
ans et qu'ils disent mais maintenant je
deviens pas famille suivent ils auront
le droit ou pas est-ce que je règle
alors là oui ça aussi c'est une
ambiguïté voilà et la troisième chose
c'est l'irlande parce qu'il y en a quand
même je rappelle que tous les pays les
27 ils ont tous un droit de veto il
suffit qu'un pays disent non et toustou
suisse tout est par terre pour
évidemment pour l'irlande c'est vital de
ne pas rétablir des frontières vraiment
alioui la seule chose qu'on va faire
c'est que dans les années qui viennent
on appliquera le droit européen des deux
côtés de la frontière mais en fait c'est
repoussé à plus tard donc en fait les
européens
à mon sens on craque et presque autant
que le gouvernement britannique était
proche de craquer parce que
effectivement theresa may ont la vue
d'un des épisodes précédents étaient
proches de sauter le premier ministre
est plus une majorité il fallait trouver
une solution et d'une certaine manière
les aînés et pour moi les européens ont
commencé à craquer et je pense qu'ils
vont craquer encore plus fort quand on
va commencer à discuter des conditions
réelles de statut futur je vais pas
faire un trop long tunnel
mais voilà et donc parce qu'il y aura
des forces très importante qui diront
bon écoutez vous êtes gentil mais nous
on veut pouvoir continuer à compte qu'on
a à faire du commerce ou librement à
commencer par les indh automobile
rappelle à une chose toutes les usines
d'automobiles britannique appartiennent
à des groupes continentaux les où ils
sont soit allemand en général n'ont
d'ailleurs portières boire pour vauxhall
donc de toutes façons on va voir chez
nous des gens qui vont dire mes foulées
laisser rentrer vous laisser rentrer
parce qu'on veut que nous attendrait vie
vous dire c'est que voilà en ce qui
concerne le marché unique c'est pas du
tout tranché parce qu'on nomme élevé
laurence de charette si on a bien
compris le l'accord dit alors les bleus
royaume-uni sortira du marché unique
sauf si on n'arrive pas à trouver un
accord
et dans ces cas là il pourrait y rester
ce qui fait que des deux côtés l'irlande
en décomptant les irlandais du nord
parce que ils croient qu'ils vont sortir
parce qu'ils sont attachés au royaume
uni et les irlandais du sud qui sont un
état européen
la république d'irlande qui est dit mais
non pas du tout on va rester unis sur
cette question là aussi bien que sur la
question de la cour de justice
européenne et c'est vrai que l'europe a
fait ce qu'elle sait faire une ambiguïté
qui permet de sortir par le haut ou par
le bas c'est pas très bien ce qu'on a
établi là c'est pendant ces neuf mois
c'est peut-être c'est la volonté de
divorcer
on a parlé beaucoup de gros sous comme
souvent dans un divorce mais on n'a pas
du tout établi les modalités du divorce
et
il reste encore je pense beaucoup
d'écueils beaucoup travaillent devant
louis devant nous je me place un coup de
pied qui veulent sortir de l'autre côté
qui viendra du côté des britanniques
en fait les anglais disait on va sortir
du l'union européenne que ça nous coûte
trop cher et finalement là si ça leur
coûte 40 50 55 milliards on sait pas
exactement
peut-être que les anglais vont changer
d'avis finalement peut-être que tony
blair qui avait dit au figaro il
faudrait peut-être voter l'aurait raison
les opinions publiques sont toujours
très versatile ça on le sait bien la
seule chose c'est que dans cette affaire
pendant la campagne sur une brique site
on me disait qu'il allait y avoir une de
crise économique sans précédent si
jamais le précité voter ensuite on nous
a dit maintenant qu'il était admis par
l'opinion publique ça n'allait jamais
réussir à se réaliser
il y aurait une crise diplomatique on
s'aperçoit que on arrive toujours à
sortir d'une situation alors plus ou
moins dème ça c'est clair
mais en l'occurrence très sincèrement
aujourd'hui on ne sait absolument pas
enfin moi en tout cas mais je suis
peut-être pas suffisamment c'est rude en
la matière mais je ne sais absolument
pas comment véritablement les choses
vont se passer d'une bonne vue de la
politique je sais bien que c'est le
niveau 0 1 mais ça a un impact ça je
connais un peu mieux
ça a un impact par exemple sur les
élections de 2010 9 et sur la
composition des groupes politiques au
parlement européen je rappelle qu'il ya
deux partis politiques les conservateurs
et le you keep qui sont au centre ils
sont définis dorsale de deux groupes
politiques au parlement européen et donc
le retrait du royaume uni provoquera
sans aucun doute une recomposition des
groupes au parlement européen la de ce
point de vue là on en est absolument
pour le coup absolument certain pour ce
qui est des modalités exactes je dirais
du retrait du royaume uni très
sincèrement ce soir on ne sait
absolument pas précisément comment les
choses vont se faire
on est encore dans le brouillard mais on
n'est pas tombé dans le fossé en toile à
benjamin grange
alors moi je suis pas aussi critique que
vous parce qu'on sait que dans une
négociation le temps finalement n'est
pas linéaire
et là on assiste finalement à une
stratégie des petits pas avec une
première étape qui peut être un accord
très partiels sur lequel comme vous
dites on sait pas grand chose et que le
reste finalement et est encore immense
mais en tout cas c'est une c'est une
première étape est de dire qu'en termes
de communication de ce projet de divorce
il y en avait besoin parce que ça fait
des essais ça fait des mois que l'on dit
on travaille on travaille on travaille
sans aucun accord est finalement avec
même à un moment une forme de retour en
arrière possible ça mais mettez ça mais
été bloqué et là finalement c'est un
acte qui est une forme de cliquer anti
retour et il en valait la crédibilité de
jean claude juncker et de l'europe qui
était finalement la victime puisqu'elle
a pris acte de la décision anglaise et
donc il lui fallait finalement montré
que ça ça avance et donc en l'occurrence
je pense que c'était une première étape
de communication qui existent dans cette
étape on va faire court mais lisez dans
cette étape lie avec mon à volonté
affichée pour cette première étape de
montrer aux opinions publiques
européennes continentales que toute
tentative de sortie se paierait le
maximum voilà et ça c'était un objectif
on est un vivier notamment par leur
gouvernement français pour bouillant
pour dissuader les autres pour bien
montrer y compris saint usage interne en
france et a montré par exemple ceux qui
auraient aux électeurs par exemple du
front national et aboulaye quitter
l'union européenne ont regardé combien
ça va coûter et ben c'est ça c'était un
des objectifs de cette première étape la
deuxième une fois ça il en fallait
montrer que ça coûte cher
et ben moi je pense que la démonstration
n'est pas fait voilà oui au moins deux
semaines
on a montré ça veut dire parce qu'on y
est heureux mais parce que ça coûterait
plus cher d'en sortir que d'y rester
c'est pas c'est pas mon nom c'est que
effectivement je pense c'est l'europe
qui répartit puni qu'ils voulaient c'est
vrai alors on se rend on souhaite la
bienvenue à tous les internautes qui
nous ont rejoints qui font des
commentaires comme toujours pertinent
sur laquelle laurence de charette vous
allez pouvoir réagir
commentaire de joch par exemple il nous
dit et bien vivement le fch excite
tandis qu'hugo gagneux nous dit c'est
quand même une faillite de l'europe le
break si tu ne vas qu'accélérer la
dislocation du royaume uni et exacerber
les tentations régionalistes c'est vrai
lorsque il ya les irlandais où on voit
que ça commence à chauffer il ya les
causes qui se dirait peut-être que moi
je resterai bien en europe
il ya même londres qui disait que
j'aimerais bien avoir un statut un peu
dérogatoire le royaume qui sera
peut-être moins unis à l'avenir oui
alors le royaume sera évidemment il ya
un tas de portes sont ouvertes ou en
tout cas potentiellement et un tas de
danger s'agit enfin de danger en tout
cas de dislocation c'est vrai que les
anglo saxons affirme une volonté très
forte sur ce point ils ont obtenu gain
de cause ils ont montré ben on veut pas
se faire dicter nos lois on veut choisir
notre immigration là dessus c'est une
prime effectivement à l'affirmation de
la volonté
l'exemple catalan a montré que ça marche
pas toujours voilà alors paul nous dit
le général de gaulle était un
visionnaire
quand il manifesté sa désapprobation
d'incorporer l'angleterre dans l'europe
très heureux du break 6 points
d'exclamation finalement guillaume
herlin le général avait raison une fois
de plus nécessairement sur tous les
sujets bien là en l'occurrence sur sa
défiance vis-à-vis je dirais du royaume
uni ya une chose qui évidemment doit
être prise en considération et qui
explique peut-être le fait que de toute
façon le break site va fonctionner à la
fin c'est l' équilibre au sein du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
parce que si la construction européenne
abouti un jour à l'établissement d'un
état fédéral ce n'est pas encore le glas
ça veut donc dire que le siège permanent
de la france le siège permanent du
royaume uni devraient fusionner avec le
break site ou moins je dirais les
etats-unis ont toujours deux alliés au
conseil de sécurité met donc en place
les corps effectivement là on peut
penser qu'il ya des enjeux qui
dépasseraient largement je dirais les
simples opinions publiques événements
jeu et les enjeux comment dire
juridiques même si naturellement ce qui
explique le break side c'est ça c'est la
volonté de reprendre gérer le contrôle
de son destin
du point de vue j'ai des rêves
territoriale et du point de vue normatif
mais nathan est ce qu'on a eu une idée
de combien de temps ça pourrait encore
durer cette ismail on les ya deux ans
mais a compris un délai de deux ans
supplémentaires
m colas avait tracé pas forcément très
confortable c'était aulas donc il reste
un an données normalement il y avait
c'était de l'article 50 d une fois
déclenché ces deux c'était un délai de
deux ans ce qui prévient la sortie par
lequel le gouvernement britannique a dit
j'ai décidé c'est la loque nous avons
décidé de sortir une vous enclenchons le
normalement un compte à rebours de deux
ans et donc il reste à peu près une
année
ok si bien compris il y aurait un délai
de deux ans supplémentaires pendant
lesquels la grande-bretagne appliquerait
toutes les règles du marché unique sans
avoir plus aucune plus plus personne
dans les instances décisionnaires de la
de l'union européenne aura plus de
parlementaires européens les élections
en 2019
il n'y aurait plus il y aurait plus de
commissaires et caetera et aurait quand
même à mon avis encore beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de hauts fonctionnaires ou une
à bruxelles parce que des choses qu'un
casque conçu faire les britanniques
c'est de bien investir la commission
européenne et
en fait il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
fonctionnaires ce qui explique un peu
aussi l'orientation lens si on prend un
peu de recul quand le break site est
arrivé ça a été un coup de tonnerre et
on s'est dit c'est peut-être la fin de
l'europe parce qu'on craignait qu'ils
aient un effet domino se dire que le
royaume uni sorte que derrière il ya un
succès ou poussée des populistes aux
pays bas en france aussi avec les
élections présidentielles de 2017 et et
marine le pen qui qui aurait pu être
dangereuse même si elle n'était pas élu
prêtera puis finalement on a
l'impression que l'incendié est maîtrisé
en quelques secondes en fait ce qu'on
voit c'est que ça rapporte chacun a son
histoire et que nous n'avons pas la même
histoire c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait la
difficulté de l'europe et c'est
paradoxalement ce qui aujourd'hui
maintient une forme de cohésion enfin en
tout cas bloc satisfait de contagion
dont vous parler parce que la
problématique des anglais n'est pas du
tout la même que celle des catalans des
espagnols et la façon dont probablement
l'europe va ressurgir dans notre débat
électoral d'ici quelques mois ne se
posera pas non plus complètement de la
même façon enfin quelques problématiques
vont venir mais on n'est pas dans le
même cas de figure
l'europe ne va pas très bien mais quand
on se compare on se console disait ma
grand mère elle pour garder le parti
socialiste français elle s'aperçoit que
finalement son sort n'est pas si
difficile pardon pour cette transition
un peu laborieuse
c'est notre deuxième thème de la soirée
parti socialiste faut-il qu'ils
disparaissent la question est un peu
provocatrice mais c'est aussi un appel à
vous les internautes voter sur le
hashtag figaro live #primaires point de
vue tout attaché et répondez à cette
question si ça vous intéresse
faut-il que le ps disparaissent en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il est en
danger de mort vous savez le dernier
épisode c'est la création par benoît
hamon qui était le candidat socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle de son parti
ou de son mouvement génération point s
est ce que le ps est en danger de mort
écouter ce qu'en disait frédérique
espagnac c'est une sénatrice socialiste
des pyrénées-atlantiques que pour être
précis et elle était hier matin
l'invitée d'yves thréard au talk le
figaro
ça peut vous faire de l'ombre au parti
socialiste ce mouvement génération s'est
passé une histoire d'hommes c'est encore
une histoire de division à gauche je
crois que la gauche va déjà mal et donc
j'ai envie de dire en tout cas on a
besoin de rassemblement aujourd'hui le
parti socialiste peut mourir dans ces
conditions oui je pense
faut faire attention et
les internautes qui commencent à voter
c'est vous qui nous regarde et vous êtes
à peu près même très précisément 71% à
dire oui il faut que le parti socialiste
dise pareil ça est ce que ça vous étonne
observé nathan exactement est ce que
vous pensez souhaitable que finalement
il est ce qu'on appelle un reset en
informatique ses terres on recommence
tout je pense qu'il faut faire un reset
mais il faut s'entendre
je pense que le courant socialiste les
candidats socialistes va perdurer
parce que il vient de très loin et en
fait je pense qu'il a encore un avenir
pour les idées qu'ils ont pour certaines
des idées qu'il porte en revanche qui
évidemment en train de dc dc le parti
socialiste qu'on a qui est né en 1971
qu'on congrès d'epinay c'est ça qui
meurt c'est pas le congrès c'est pas le
parti de jean jaurès qui m'aurait c'est
éventuellement la destruction est
peut-être la transformation ensuite
ultérieure de cette forme particulière
qu'a pris le cac a pris socialisme avec
ça
guidés par françois mitterrand en 1971
avec jean pierre chevènement derrière
qui était le quitte et inspirateur
idéologique avec un mais il faut se
rappeler quelque chose ça qui est qui
manque dans la dans la réflexion des
socialistes c'est que ce parti là c'est
fait s'est constitué pepino 1071 tout ce
qu' il était sur un mouvement social
puissant qui venait on était trois ans
après mai 1968 et même des comptes des
conflits ouvriers etc qui était bien
bien bien qu'ils remontaient à bien
avant et donc il y avait un vrai courant
qui portait le parti socialiste est
l'erreur dans mon oeil fait madame et
espagnac par exemple c'est de considérer
que le socialisme peut exister en dehors
de ça voilà je pense qu'il ne peut
renaître qu'avec un mouvement social
je vois d'un point de vue de guillaume
d'un internaute qui nous dit on peut se
dire que quand on ne représente plus
rien on n'a plus de légitimité et on
doit se réinventer
je me tourne vers un autre guillaume
pour savoir s'il est d'accord avec cette
assertion
vous savez tout le monde le sait le
parti socialiste a été comment dire
incohérence et dire qu'il a continué à
s'appeler socialiste en étant devenu
social démocrate dont par conséquent si
vous voulez
il est évident que l'étiquette ne fait
pas la nature réelle du parti est la
conséquence est la conséquence on l'a vu
la dernière présidentielle il a été
siphonné d'un côté et de l'autre par le
social-libéral macron et par
effectivement le socialiste mélenchon
le problème pour le pour le parti
socialiste c'est que outre le score
qu'il a fait à la présidentielle il a
perdu les élections locales antérieures
c'est à dire qu'ils ne disposent plus je
dirais de du socialisme municipal qui
avait permis pendant des décennies au
parti socialiste à la force socialiste
de continuer à exister et et d'avoir je
dirais un réservoir de cadres bon donc
aujourd'hui la seule chance finalement
pour le parti socialiste me semble-t-il
de continuer à exister
c'est la division de la france insoumise
mais quand et vision car les jacobins et
les communautaristes et si cette
division là perdure effectivement le
parti socialiste peut être espérait
renaître de ses cendres
imaginez si l'on imaginé c'est une
hypothèse d'école qui ont permis que
vous soyez élu premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
une hôtesse vous supprimerez le parti
pour créer autre chose ou pas ce qu'il
faut est ce qu'il faut faire table rase
aujourd'hui très sincèrement les forces
politiques telle qu'elle existait avant
la grande coalition macro nien son ont
du plomb dans l aile je crois
qu'effectivement il faut recomposer
aussi bien du côté droit de macron que
du côté gauche les maquereaux donc c'est
oui au oui mais on a bien compris et
hugo gagneux qui a aussi un point de vue
sur sur ce sujet nous dit il faut que le
ps se modernise avec un leader comme
malek boutih
quand en marche exposera l'espace centre
gauche se libérera et le clivage
gauche-droite remettra ça ce qu'on
appelle de la prospective
benjamin anges alors
en fait je vais quasiment enfoncer le
clou puisqu'on a dans un sondage le 30
novembre dernier posé la question aux
français
et finalement ils sont 74% à considérer
que le pronostic est que le parti
socialiste allait disparaître le point
nouveau c'est que c'est aussi 63% des
sympathisants de gauche
alors ce qui est ce qui est frappant
c'est surtout que si on compare ça par
rapport à septembre 2016
juste après finalement la débâcle
électorale eh bien ils n'étaient que 63
% c'est-à-dire pratiquement 10 points de
moins à considérer que le parti
socialiste allait allait disparaître
alors quand on creuse derrière pourquoi
finalement on sait comment dire ce
pronostic est si important et bien c'est
on retrouve un certain nombre de
qualificatifs comme il n'a guère de
conviction il n'est pas proche des gens
il n'est pas adapté aux évolutions du
monde et il n'est même pas utile à la
vie politique à la vie politique
française
et finalement quand on a ce portrait là
on pourra dire noir c'est noir
on pourrait reprendre au 6e
sartre qui disait on soit chambre de la
gauche c'est un grand cadavre à la
renverse
bien plus que ça où les verts se sont
mis en tout cas aujourd'hui on en est là
donc voilà on est proche de l'avis de
décès d'ailleurs nos internautes ne
changent pas d'avis sont toujours 70 % à
penser qu' il faut qu'ils disparaissent
et vous laurence de charette allez-vous
donner dst un peu d'espoir à nos
camarades même plus la rue solférino
puisqu'il l'a met en vente
vous avez bien sûr de 4 proposait le
poste de dirigeant parce qu'il ya assez
peu de candidats moi je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec avec hervé nathan
finalement donc on voit qu'il n'ya pas
de candidat il n'y a pas deux il ya plus
de sièges
y'a bon c'est un appareil en
déliquescence mais pour ce qui est
également de son projet c'est pas très
facile à déterminer il ya un parti
tiraillé enfin partie en tout cas voilà
des des représentants qui sont tiraillés
entre les sociaux-démocrates et
l'extrême gauche
et puis toute la polémique on a eu
renaître récemment qui sépare les islamo
gauchiste des véritables républicain et
finalement comment doigt ce qu'est ce
qu'il reste du caleçon lesquels et le la
ligne directrice du ps qu'elle devrait
teckel devrait-elle être on s'y perd
complètement
alors moi j'invite vous rendez vous
transformer en chasseur de tête je vais
vous donner des candidats possibles pour
le poste de premier secrétaire
vous allez me dire qui et qui vous
paraît le plus le plus adapté alors on
commence par le seul pour l'instant des
candidats officiellement déclarés
luc carvounas que tu as un député il ya
aussi une najat vallaud belkacem
l'ancien ministre l'ancien ministre
comme ça qu'on dit aujourd'hui de
l'éducation nationale qui sont très
intéressé par le job
bahia françois hollande qui n'a pas
complètement disparu de la circulation
laurence on parlait à l'instant du ce
débat sur l'islam bail à manuel valls
qui a pris des positions très fortes
vagues sur c'est vrai qu'il est plus
parti socialiste vous avez réservé est
ce qui pourrait revenir
est-ce que vous avez un candidat idéal
non je dis l'année certaine manière mais
pour je suis assez d'accord finalement
mais on se rejoint cfa 3 jeux je pense
qu'effectivement là il n'y a plus aucun
élan au parti de vos parti socialiste
celui qui est néanmoins 71 après il ya
pour moi la possibilité
philosophiquement de dire il y aura
toujours une idée socialiste et heures
peut-être qu'elle est en france à
sourice peut-être qu'effectivement la
france a soumis ce round
une partie de la recomposition de la
gauche mais il n'y a pas de possibilité
de recomposer un parti un parti qui soit
une alternative politique en dehors d'un
mouvement social qui lui porterait parce
que c'est ce faux le on aurait tort de
négliger ce qui s'était passé en santé
oms et parce qu'il y avait un mouvement
ascendant sociale qui a porté et le
parti socialiste était le dépositaire
politiques des mouvements sociaux et
c'est ça qui l'a porté en 80 c'est grâce
à ça avec à ce moment ça peut changer la
vie
et grâce à ça il avait une terrain gagné
bon déjà faire même bien à tj avec est
ravi de signer gonelle pc absolue
avancée permet normale étant assez laid
c'est de se dire mais une partie de nos
idées vont qu'à macquart vidéo mais
justement le positionnement davantage
oui mais comme à la re mettre d'accord
mais comment faisait le parti socialiste
de cette époque là pour siphonner une
partie des voix du parti communiste il
était le meilleur représentant des
luttes que le parti communiste se ce
n'est plus notamment les luttes des
femmes par exemple on prend la question
de la lutte pour le pour la
libéralisation de l'avortement c'est
parti socialiste et yvette roudy qui
était en tête et le parti est parti
communiste il avait entraîné encore
jeannette vermeersch qui cinq années
plus tôt disait que jamais les
prolétaires ne serait d'accord pour
avorter c'était ça donc effectivement le
parti communiste et fait siphonné mais
parce que il y avait un mouvement social
il fallait répondre et le parti
communiste s'est fait prendre en défaut
il arrête t on avec les soigneurs évoqué
par la roquette
non ok mais je suis d'accord mais bon vu
l'air et charismatique et nous
entraînons mais qu'on voit un risque sa
vie durant est ce que vous pouvez faire
correspondre lucas ou un quelconque des
noms que vous avez cités là à la réponse
un problème profond de la société peut
être manuel valls comme manuel à ces
partis chez les républicains marche je
trouve que là c'est un peu compliqué
mais il ya malgré tout yves hugon disais
pourquoi pas qui est aussi cas aussi des
positions très fermes sur le fond le
refus du communautarisme et fo après
faut être capable d'élargir d'être le
col
l'homme qui représente ça et pas
seulement l'homme le programme bon en
biscuit tout ça n'existait pas encore
s'est fait pas sur les listes
l'ambiguïté que vous avez évoqué c'est
est-ce que c'est l'idée socialisme
spécial idées progressistes
oui l'auteur effectivement qu'alimenter
socialiste très sincèrement je pense que
une toute forme de collectivisme même
chez je reste collectivise permettait le
maintien de la propriété privée
aujourd'hui toute forme de collectivisme
je dirais et quand même a quand même peu
le vent en poupe et donc par conséquent
effectivement c'est plutôt le
progressisme et dans ce cas là c'est du
libéralisme et macro l'incarnation elle
a incarné donc effectif alors il ya
peut-être d'autres possibilités mais
voilà un message personnel pour josh qui
nous dit moi je veux bien être président
du ps s'il cherche et bien je changerais
envoyer votre candidature sans faute aux
6es du parti une fois qu'on aura trouvé
où il est majeur ma grange alors dans le
jeu de trouver les leaders on avait posé
une question qui était de dire toujours
le 30 novembre
laquelle de ces personnalités souhaitez
vous représentez souhaité ou qu'elle
représente la gauche aux prochaines
élections de 2022 alors à 34 % des
sympathisants de gauche on avait benoît
hamon bon on a vu effectivement que il
avait voilà transit est parti ensuite
vient arnaud montebourg 19 % et la jat
devient qui en 16 % manuel valls 13% et
stéphane le foll 8%
donc en fait on voit bien à travers 5 il
y en a aucun des grands leaders qui se
dégage en tout cas des leaders restant
guillaume naudi les classes populaires
et ouvrières socle de l'électorat ps pc
ont disparu en france en poids
démographique c'est vrai que ça peut
être une explication et hugo nous dit
sinon pourquoi pas une union avec le
nouveau parti radical avec mon avis et
de la porte il avala c'est le chemin
tout tracé vers le vert l'elysée lorsque
chirac quand on voit la structure de
popularité de d'emmanuel mac on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait il est plus
populaire à droite qu'à gauche peut-être
que ça ça pourrait rouvrir un espace non
au parti socialiste
quand on voit ce président qui supprime
l'impôt sur la fortune qui libéralise le
code du travail qui fait l'éloge de jean
d'ormesson une sauce sur la pierre
attention sur l'immobilier c'est quand
même une certaine catégorie de riches
mais pas tous mais mais lorsque vous
pensez que c'est bas avec un maquereau
qui sont plutôt de droite en tout cas en
économie ça pourrait redonner de
l'oxygène à un futur parti socialiste
alors ben paradoxalement c'est ce qu'on
dit ça c'est à dire finalement
emilien mâcon s'est fait élire avec un
programme qui n'était pas aussi affirmé
sur le point de vue libéral économique
est finalement là dessus chacune des
positions qui prend avance de plus en
plus ça grignote tout le terrain de
hockey
et paradoxalement sur les questions
sociétales il est plus à gauche mais ces
questions sociétales étant des gens a
déjà représenté
il reste plus que najat vallaud belkacem
qui pour elle est sur représentée à
gauche qui pourrait être plus
provocatrice allait peut-être plus loin
si on voulait laisser au parti
socialiste
si on cherche un boulot parti socialiste
puisque c'est ça qu'on lui cherche des
candidats missionnement et j'avoue que
je peine à lonato tout pour être un
finalement 1,1 à liés à la
reconstruction du ps emmanuel ma croix
par sa politique économique un peu
libérée on va en tout cas c'est pas
l'impression qu'ils n'ont plutôt
l'impression qu'ils valent à peine à
prescrire du saut là non il
si on veut parler comme sa tactique
politicienne impression que c'est la
stratégie casse-noisette on va peut-être
ici des élections européennes bientôt
mais et élections européennes on voit
bien que les l'idée c'est que yes et 2c
de détruire tout ce qu'il ya entre la
république en marche et la france est
soumise à côté puis de l'autre côté il
ya la symétrie entre le front national
donc je pense l'allier en tout cas c'est
un
c'est le baiser du cycle cherche là
l'expression désamorcer les critiques
des chartes vous n'êtes pas très
optimiste pour l'avenir du parti
socialiste est-ce que ça a fait changer
d'avis les internautes ou est-ce qu'on
est toujours à 70%
et bien non ça reste 70 % donc la sphère
est fait et nous allons pouvoir passer
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
pour nous intéresser aux républicains
c'est
ce week-end de l'élection à la
présidence de ce parti uniquement pour
les membres des républicains les
adhérents qui vont qui vont voter
laurent wauquiez est le grand favori
pour autant il ne fait pas l'unanimité
au sein de son parti
écoutez la dernière méchanceté en date
c'est celle de jean louis debré
président du conseil constitutionnel
il était ce matin sur france info et il
hésite et a décerné à laurent wauquiez
un brevet de gaullisme
regardez moi je suis profondément
gaulliste comme jean d'ormesson été
gaullisme à laurent wauquiez blicquy les
gaullistes c'est possible mais je n'ai
jamais vu avant voilà avec des avec des
amis comme ça on n'a plus besoin
d'ennemis
guillaume bernad le positionnement de
laurent wauquiez est ce qu il est aussi
clair que le reproche que lui font ses
adversaires c'est à dire il est à droite
toute
il est certain que dans son discours
personnel et dans l'attitude qu'il a on
l'a vu par exemple avec la sphère des
crèches il assume une position droite
hier donc je dirais une vise évidemment
les militants les sympathisants du parti
pour avoir un soutien un soutien
populaire
on sait bien que la base d'un parti
politique est toujours plus à droite que
les caciques je dirais bon mais d'un
autre côté évidemment laurent wauquiez
il a besoin je dirais pour essayer de
maintenir le restant d'unité du parti va
d'avoir des alliés pour essayer de
d'éviter je dirais une destruction donc
il y avait un gimmick al calmels syli à
geoffroy didier voilà qui évidemment
sont je dirais d'aider des moyens d'être
un peu dans une position attrape tout
donc c'est vrai que c'est une position
inconfortable puisque c'est le grand
écart c'est à la fois je dirais avoir le
soutien de la base par un discours
droitier mais en même temps essayer de
maintenir l'unité de l'appareil on peut
penser que à l'avenir lorsqu'il va
s'agir non pas simplement de désigner un
un patron du parti mais il va falloir
déterminer un programme un
positionnement établir des listes pour
les élections par exemple les élections
européennes un là pour le coup les les
grands du parti vont évidemment essayer
de je dirais de l'attendre au coin de au
coin de la rue donc c'est vrai que
vraisemblablement à votre question oui
il devrait gagner parce que ses
concurrents à la présidence de l air son
jeu
certes je dirais intéressant mais non
pas la visibilité qu'il qui la met en
revanche ça ne veut pas dire qu'il va
pouvoir contrôler véritablement
l'appareil et en faire ce qu'ils le
désirent alors vous êtes invités à l'
d'un répondre à cette question
wauquiez va-t-il réussir tant que sur le
hashtag fear alive acheter un point de
vue point de vue au pluriel tout attaché
pour l'instant 49% des
internautes disent non voquer ne va pas
réussi non pas avancer ça c'est 49% qui
dit oui il va réussir ça c'est mon côté
optimiste et sa portière pour cent qui
disent non il va pas réussir pour
comprendre un petit peu plus ce qu'est
l'état d'esprit des électeurs de droite
nous avons fait notre sondage
hebdomadaire avec nos amis de doxa et
benjamin c'est vous qui allez nous le
commentait quels sont les enseignements
de ce sondage
alors en fait quand on interroge les
sympathisants et l'air c'est un petit
peu plus que les internautes
d'aujourd'hui puisque ils sont 62% à
considérer que s'il était adhérent et
bien laurent wauquiez il voterait pour
laurent wauquiez
laurent wauquiez qui sort évidemment
comme comme un grand favori mais on est
on s'achemine plutôt vers une victoire
qu'on pourrait qualifier à la pyrrhus
parce que cette large domination elle
doit être relativisée relativiser parce
que durant sa campagne
finalement il a perdu du terrain si on
compare finalement sa cote de popularité
auprès des sympathisants à l'air et bien
elle a perdu 16 points en deux mois
et puis ensuite évidemment terme de
notoriété il est face à des compétiteurs
qui sont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
moins connu et donc il ya une prime pour
lui alors le deuxième point qui est
important est de c'est le deuxième
enseignement c'est quand on creuse
finalement l'image en détail du futur
patron des républicains
hélas hélas on voit que il ya une
majorité de français est d'ailleurs bon
nombre de sympathisants et l'eire qui ne
le trouvent ni honnête à 60%
les sympathiques à 55 ni proche des gens
à 62% et donc
forcément ça pose question alors on
s'est mis à creuser les choses alors si
la régie peut nous mettre ce que on a
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est de
regarder évidemment ce qu'on en dit et
donc vous avez sur cette voie là sur
cette cartographie vous savez ces
petites icônes qui donne un peu les
sentiments et alors il y en a deux qui
sont qui sont amusants donc le premier
amusé en tout cas le premier qui ressort
c'est finalement cette flèche en bas qui
clairement veux mentionner que c'est pas
très intéressant le débat mais le
deuxième est plus intéressant c'est le
deuxième tir sort c'est le pinocchio et
ça illustre finalement voilà toute cette
perception de pas forcément de très
grandes de très grands de honnêteté
alors ce chat avez vous des éléments
peuvent leur encore qu'est ce qu'ils
écoutent
comment dire c'est mieux qu'au ps oui on
voit que c'est pas c'est pas gagné à
passer le premier tour avant son
élection est en quasi assuré son son job
n'ait pas gagné moi il reste beaucoup de
travail et c'est d'autant plus difficile
que son son premier job on va dire c'est
d'être de reconquérir les lettres de
premiers opposants mais ça emmanuel
macron est pas prêt à laisser faire
parce qu'il y en a vraiment aucun
intérêt mélenchon est un opposant
parfait
d'abord parce qu'il est quand même moins
faux nîmes on peut faire ce plaisir
ok et deuxièmement parce qu'il a le
grand mérite d'expliquer aux électeurs
de droite que macro est bien plus
intéressant que wauquiez alors tout ça
c'est un piège et commanditaires je
pense ce piège va continuer à agir pour
les européennes le mois de mai a dit
nous a rejoint du figaro.fr bonsoir mais
roanne alors vous êtes allez vous
plonger sur les dents les réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous vous confirmer
cette spécialité un peu critique dont
nous parlait benjamin ou pas je confirme
là pour le coup je suis allé dans les
commentaires sous le sondage du jour est
donc dans les commentaires il ya deux
communautés qui s'affrontent ce sont
ceux qui croient en laurent wauquiez
pour dimanche 6 et lure il y arrivera
est ce qu'il trouve stupide justement
ceux qui pensent qu'il va relever le
niveau
alors on a notamment wang li qui nous
dit ce qui se dit ou s'écrit sur
wauquiez est ahurissant cela fait des
mois que les candidats de droite qui ont
tous échoué directement ou par jeunes
candidats interposés temps de dézinguer
le favori c'est pitoyable
la jalousie transpire de leurs propos
dans la même veine on aille à l
à 478 qui nous dit je suis de droite
classique et je ne comprends pas
l'avalanche de critiques qui tombe sur
wauquiez proches du fn je ne le crois
pas si parler d'identité nationale est
réservé au front national il faut nous
le dire
est il proche de sens commun si un
mouvement chrétien constitue un problème
pour l r j'en tirerai les conséquences
qui s'imposent
josé maria qui nous dit laurent wauquiez
incarne l'espoir tangibles pour plus de
14 millions de retraités qui sont
maltraités fiscalement par macron
partout où je vais amis connaissances on
ne parle plus que de wauquiez en termes
élogieux dommage de devoir vieillir de
quatre ans de plus avant de voir la
lumière et de pouvoir souffler un peu
et enfin on a les autres notamment gaby
grain de sel qui nous dit je suis de
droite classique et je coince avec vos
pieds c'est un personnage
remarquablement intelligent mais qui
n'inspire ni confiance ni amitié il sera
lui aussi uniquement jugés sur son bilan
mais je doute de sa capacité à incarner
la france comme président et enfin jean
claude baillet qui nous dit gêné d'être
habitant lyon avec cette personne comme
président de région
que fait-il pas grand chose rien il m'a
fait penser à trump
il devient boss d'aider la pub lique 1
je lui envoie ma carte vieille de 25 ans
enfin si il a même destin présidentiel
que trump à tous il ya peut-être une
stratégie à hervé nathan
oui c'est vrai que la difficulté qu'on
voit laurent wauquiez c'est de sortir du
personnage qui s'est construit lui-même
quand on fait quand on voit le parcours
de en moquez quand même quelqu'un qui
commet chez les démocrates chrétiens et
qui maintenant est en train d'en cas
apparemment de flirter avec le front
national
donc c'est ainsi qu'un personnel fin
jeudi apparemment mal à moi d'erevan
d'accord avec vous on vous donnera la
parole après m
voilà donc on verra pour le moment là sa
stratégie sans mines auraient de toute
façon les chances sont de son camp
d'arriver un jour au gouvernement
je pense que d'une certaine manière
c'est ce que cherche on le disait ce
qu'est ce que cherchent les maquereaux
niasse et de leur poussée de ce côté là
et que pour le moment il a l'air de deux
trous énormes
j'avais trouvé de trouver cette voie
comme la voix lui la voix de sa chance
je j'ai du mal ay croire guillaume
bernard oui je réagissais là sur la
question de la proximité avec le front
national
il a dès juillet dernier donc après les
législatives pris une position alors que
d'ailleurs personne ne lui demandait
pris une position extrêmement claire sur
le fait qu' il n'a doumbé plus la
stratégie du ni lit mais qu'il voulait à
tout prix réinstaller le cordon
sanitaire jalonné nice était bannie pour
macron voilà encore mariés juste après
avoir dit qu au moment des échéances et
moment où on voit qu'elle est là notre
politique c'est un moment lui pose des
questions
monsieur monsieur wauquiez entre entre
entre monsieur macro et madame le pen
que vous choisissez vous ai dit je ne
choisis pas puis après il dit reste
quand même il aurait fallu que je
choisisse meilleur pour un pur quand on
prétend à la plus haute fonction de
l'état et avoir le doigt sur beuvron
nucléaire je pense qu'il vaut mieux
avoir plus de caractère que ça et on a
en tout cas le montrer aux électeurs que
ça c'est quelque chose dont on se
souvient ça c'est peut-être mieux en
saisir des données personnelles et
monique aliès tracts vous pouvez pas
dire c'est que la question de la
proximité entre vaud qui est le front
national du foyer des idées pouvaient
pas prétendre que ça ne se pose pas
comme questions politiques alors ça en
revanche je suis d'accord c'est à dire
que électoralement parlant il refuse
toute alliance mais en revanche ils
développent plus ou moins une stratégie
à la ligne buisson
c'est à dire une droitisation de son
propre discours pour essayer
effectivement de 2 comment dire de
capter un électorat à terme et qui est
un électorat qui est déçu du front
national et essayer effectivement de
reconstituer une droite je dirais à son
profit le problème c'est que on en a
parlé tout à l'heure le ps et je dirais
écartelée entre la france insoumise et
macron et l air le risque aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il soit en revanche écrasé
entre macron et le front national parce
qu'évidemment les prochaines échéances
électorales
ce sont les européennes et la même si
marine le pen est décrédibilisé du point
de vue de sa propre personne il est
certain que le dit
pour re sceptiques du front national et
arrive en bloc
tandis qu évidemment et l'air est
parfaitement divisés sur cette position
est donc vous imaginez une liste
nationale l air aux européennes avec un
souverainiste un fédéraliste un
eurosceptique et c'est à ça va ne
ressemblait à rien donc c'est évidemment
ça la très grande difficulté que
lectorat et donc électorale du front
national ira voter front national et ce
qu'ils euros oui on va voir peut être un
dernier une dernière question de notre
sondage aux ducks à benjamin grange et
peut-être qu'il remontera un peu le
moral de laurent wauquiez
quand même c'est pas le plus mauvais
candidat aux yeux des électeurs de
droite
pas pour la présidence des républicains
mais pour celle d'après celle de 2022 la
présidentielle oui alors finissons sur
une sur une note positive pour laurent
wauquiez quand on leur pose la question
et c'est quel est le meilleur candidat
évidemment les sympathisants ils
rendirent pour 2022 les sympathisants
républicains disent à 34% évidemment
laurent wauquiez on sent quand même
derrière qu'il ya une envie d'avoir un
leader qui va incarner ce parti-là et et
xavier bertrand du côté des
sympathisants républicains à rivka 23%
alors effectivement l'ordre ce qu'on dit
est un tout petit peu différente envers
l'ensemble des français mais à ce stade
il n'y a pas grand chose à en dire
toujours pour contre pour pour terminer
sur cette note positive
il ya quand même deux choses qui sont à
porter au crédit long terme d'image de
laurent wauquiez c'est que les
sympathisants les français lui
reconnaissent qu'il est dynamique
pour 58% d'entre eux ayant des
convictions pour 50% 55% contre donc la
tâche est importante mais en même temps
il a quand même de qualité sur lequel il
peut compter merci benjamin grand je
vous propose maintenant de nous
intéresser à deux personnalités que nous
aimions beaucoup je pense qu'on peut le
dire je sais pas si c'est collectif en
tout cas au figaro qui sont jean
d'ormesson et johnny hallyday je vous
remonte la couverture de marianne s'il
est encore possible de la voir qui les
associe tous les deux en dix ans les
immortels pourquoi ils sont là france
hervé nathan vous y allez pas de main
morte là c'est la fois la france c'est
johnny hallyday jean d'ormesson
c'est un hymne méritent tous les deux un
hommage national on a décidé on a décidé
de les plonger toute fin de l'est
doyenne comme quand il y avait une
concordance des temps pour moi de cacher
donc il ya 3 juin deux jours
d'intervalle ils s'angoissent voilà donc
il y avait et on a eu envie de dire deux
choses la première c'est que comme la
france quand même c'est la littérature
est certaine manière jean d'ormesson
représentait bien la littérature
française alors j'irai pas jusqu'à dire
que c'était à victor hugo se pense que
il faut essayer aussi éviter des
exagérations et rabat ont dû à ça ça se
verra dans 50 ans je crois que chez nous
on dit que il ya un des collègues de
jean d'ormesson qui disent et et victor
hugo oui mais sans les misérables ni les
travailleurs de la mer donc ça commence
pas facilement mais c'était quand même
une image de la littérature c'est vrai
que la france que les français se
reconnaissent dans la littérature si
voilà c'est la sémis il y avait une d
âme une âme à la france sa littérature
en fait partie j'en ai cantat quant à
johnny hallyday d'une certaine manière
il nous représente tous parce qu'à
chaque année il a eu sa vie a été
tellement compliqué complexe sa vie
d'artiste et sa vie personnelle qu'une
certaine manière elle a touché tous les
français les uns après les autres voire
concomitamment faut quand même se
souvient revenir tout odile tout au
début c'est sait si on a presque oublié
mais c'était l'hymne c'était quasiment
l'image du diable pour la france bien
pensante
c'était l'image des blousons noirs c'est
le concert de la nation qui fini en
émeutes et intérêts puis petit à petit
il a élargi totalement son il ya eu il
est allé faire son service mais il est
allé faire son service militaire
voilà qui était l'icône de la conception
répète l'icône une contestation
politicienne extrêmement radical au tout
début est devenu petit à petit l'ami de
nicolas sarkozy d'abord de jacques
chirac avant lui il a passé à droite et
donc d'une certaine manière voilà c'est
un parcours politique et artistique qui
finit par toucher l'ensemble de la
population ce qui fait que demain matin
j'imagine le match sera sûrement très
humour donc à cette question à laquelle
nous vous proposons aussi de répondre
johnny hallyday jean d'ormesson enfin
l'union nationale pour l'interrogation
est bien hervé nathan répond oui vous
aussi vous pouvez répondre hashtag
figaro live #primaires il y aura un
autre est d'acord sur cette unanimité
autour des deux hommes et bien c'est
jean louis debré
l'ex président du conseil
constitutionnel qu'on a entendu à
l'instant et qu'on va ré entendre
c'était ce matin sur france info
mais selon d'unanimité
soyons heureux de rendre cet hommage
alors à johnny ou à jean d'ormesson la
nation a toujours rendu des hommages à
des grands personnages je pense à paul
valéry
je pense à à maurice barrès je pense à
la première femme qui a eu des obsèques
nationales qui était colette en 1954 au
palais royal
oui il est bien une nation c'est un rêve
d'avenir partager mais c'est aussi une
histoire
alors pour l'instant 71% les internautes
répondent plutôt non à cette question
twitter sur l'union nationale guillaume
bernard ce matin j'ai insisté comme
beaucoup de gens du figaro à l'hommage
rendu par le président de la république
à jean d'ormesson dans la cour des
invalides
il y avait ces honneurs militaires
ce drapeau bleu blanc rouge sur le
cercueil est ce que on aurait dû faire
la même chose pour pour johnny hallyday
ou est-ce que vous voyez une différence
de nature entre entre ces deux parcours
cc c'est bien difficile comme question
honnêtement parce que ça laisserait
supposer qu'il faudrait des rares chizé
la valeur des hommes
et ça j'avoue que je n'oserais pas à
prendre position moi ce qui me vide
amant la situation je dirai où il ya une
certaine unanimité est extrêmement
touchante jeu j'ai plutôt quand même
tendance à penser qu' il y a j'espère
qu'il n'y aura pas demain je dirais des
scènes d'hystérie mais qu' il ya je
dirais une disproportion peut-être entre
je dirais la mort de deux personnes
parfaitement honorable et dont l'oeuvre
est intéressante et je dirais le comment
dire le l'hommage national sous les là
je vais vraiment passer pour un peu
comment dire pour un vieux rabougris
mais que voulez vous aussi voulez pour
moi l'unité de la nation
l élu pour moi l'unité de la nation c
c'est philippe auguste qui met la pâtée
à jean sans terre à bouvines pour moi
c'est condé qui met la pâtée aux
espagnols à rocroi
voilà ça pour moi évidemment c'est un
sens c'est à dire que c'est évidemment
bon alors cela dit ce qui est très
touchant c'est que incontestablement et
part je dirais une culture plutôt
intellectuelle pour jean d'ormesson et
pour une culture populaire pour johnny
hallyday
et il ya quand même dans ces deux
personnages là je dirais le signe qu'il
ya une appartenance à une culture
commune et donc là de ce point de vue là
évidemment c'est quand même quelque
chose d'important de ce que bien on se
rend compte que avec pourtant des
divisions sociales avec des divisions
politiques avec des opinions je dirais
diverses
il y a quand même je dirais une
appartenance nationale qui est réel
parce que il y à la communion dans une
même culture
pour autant est-ce qu'il faut porter aux
nues nécessairement autant qu'on le fait
je dirais de personnalités intéressantes
je suis peut-être un peu dubitatif eh
bien vous avez un allié en la personne
de jack smales qui nous dit ne soyons
pas superficiel l'union nationale sur
ces deux décès c'est ridicule comme idée
laurence de charette est ce que vous
serez sur les champs-elysées demain
matin mais en fait je pense qu'il faut
pas passer ça sous le pas sur ce jour
terme d'union nationale puisque c'est un
terme qu'un dimension politique or je
pense qu'on est plutôt dans une autre
dimension qui est plutôt de l'ordre de
l'essentialité comment
jean d'ormesson disait ben il faut pas
mourir le même jour copia fait parce que
la presse est comme cocteau on s'est
fait mettre de côté eh ben je crois que
c'est exactement l'inversé on assiste à
une semaine un peu extraordinaire où
malgré tout ces deux stars au lieu de se
manger la lumière d'une autre cela
renvoie qu'est ce qu'on a fait toute la
semaine on a parlé de générosité on a
parlé de vérité on a parlé de culture de
rock et c est en réalité c'est cette eau
de comme un commune à des valeurs autour
du rock et de la littérature taux double
aux assez improbable nous renvoie malgré
tout à une essence française est
d'ailleurs maquereau a dit aujourd'hui
la littérature c'est l'essence de la
france donc on arrive dans une forme
d'universalité qui est normalement le
propre de l'art et peut-être de l'esprit
français et demain matin dès 10h
figaro.fr retransmettra en direct jeudi
à l'idée de nous y serons et lily qui
dit à l'instant c'est joli ce que dit
laurence mais oui c'est très vrai
benjamins alors moi je me suis je me
suis intéressé à voir comment les médias
finalement relaté relatait ses hommages
alors on se confronteront peut-être
peut-être à tort sur sur johnny hallyday
puisque c'est là qu'est le plus de
volume et finalement il ya deux choses
deux choses qui ressorte la première
c'est que j'ai regardé les audiences
télé parce que finalement tout le monde
a bousculé ses programmes pour faire des
émissions spéciales et se trouve que ça
n'a pas fait recette puisque les
audiences ont été souvent inférieure à
un programme original
la deuxième chose c'est de regarder
comment cet hommage populaire c'est
s'est opéré sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est là qu'on voit finalement
comment les français utilise ce pouvoir
de résonance parce que le camp dire le
tweet qui a été le plus partagé sur
johnny hallyday c'est le tweet d'un d'un
artiste d'un chanteur qui s'appelle
sheeran qui a simplement dire je suis
triste c'est tout et qui a été qui a
brillé tant la sebring sd sobriété la
sobriété le deuxième c'est bien celui du
président maquereau et le troisième
c'est celui d'un inconnu
comme quoi on peut arriver aussi à être
en résonance
même quand on n'est pas connu mais pour
retrouver le meilleur de ces deux
personnalités
je vous signale le hors série du figaro
magazine consacré à johnny hallyday qui
est dans les kiosques et ans vous allez
voir un instant la couverture
quant à nous au figaro magazine et bien
savons voulu rendre hommage à jean
d'ormesson qui a été pendant 16 ans le
chroniqueur du fig mag
chaque semaine avec un adieu à ses
personnels avec des des témoignages de
frédéric beigbeder le critique
littéraire du fig mag de philippe
bouvard août eric neuhoff et vous hervé
nathan est ce que vous serez demain
matin sur les champs-elysées
non je pense pas que je serai sur les
champs-elysées pour des raisons
personnelles mais je pense qu'il faut
pop art faut pas négliger l'émotion
d'une partie au moins deux
de la population qui est posée par le
décès de johnny hallyday je pense que il
ya quelque chose qui tout d'un coup
assez effacé dix ans parce que d'une
certaine manière il ya toute une
génération c on a parlé beaucoup la
génération du baby boom et qui
effectivement est en train de sortir de
la scène politique n'empêche que c'est
entièrement ont reconnu entièrement le
vécu avec avec johnny hallyday
je rappelle quelque chose de ce soupçon
et ça a été dit non non et non les
différents articles ont été publiés par
les journaux mais dans il ya une
génération qui à écouter johnny hallyday
tous les soirs sur sur dans salut les
copains sur europe 1 tous les soirs il
la moitié des jeunes la mouette il faut
quand même se réduire parce que c'était
la moitié les jeunes avaient l'oreille
collée au transistor à 17h pour écouter
l'émission de philippe acquis c'est une
chose que c'est une communion que
effectivement on retrouve cinquante ans
plus tard transformé différentes mais
c'est celle là aussi qu'on retrouve et
du start et maya cette nostalgie delà
d'un paradis perdu qui était le paradis
de cette jeunesse là donc c'est un peu
là une génération entière mais qui a
compté comme dans l'histoire de ce pays
qui compte en équipe est encore en même
temps économiquement mais aussi des
retraités et qui peine encore mais qui
avait voilà qui a du poids qui est d'une
certaine manière l'impression a fait
aussi l'histoire du pays parce que c'est
la mastérisation la transformation alors
malheureusement point de vue c'est fini
pour ce soir je le regrette parce qu'on
a deux commentaires passionnants sur
laquelle on aurait pu réagir mais tant
pis je vous laisse à votre talent je les
laisse pardon à votre réflexion
jax man qui dit ce qui m'attriste c'est
la manière avec laquelle le pouvoir
exploiter ces deux décès était-il
vraiment nécessaire que brigitte macron
a ici johnny point d'interrogation
et puis renard 83 sur twitter qui nous
dit quelque chose avec lequel je suis
pas d'accord mais c'est pas pour ça que
c'est pas intéressant de deux mondes
différents
il y a d'un côté les gens du système qui
admire d'ormesson et de l'autre les
pauvres qu'ils admirent johnny je suis
pas sûr que les riches n'aime pas aussi
johnny hallyday mais merci renard 83 de
nous avoir donné votre point de vue j'ai
un dernier rendez vous à vous donner
c'est mardi prochain 12 décembre il
reste quelques places salle gaveau pour
les rencontres du figaro qui se
dérouleront avec l'historien franck
ferrand et si vous avez encore une toute
petite hésitation pour savoir si vous
prenez votre place et bien je vous
invite à regarder ce qui suit dans
quelques instants sur figaro life merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre et bon
week-end
[Musique]